Rolling Stone magazine celebrates the
burning of note Rodham as an act of
liberation meanwhile Library Journal
condemns libraries as tools of white
supremacy and anti white Democrats only
want to nominate a white guy for
president we will analyze how the West
lost its mind
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
I hate to say I told you so now I love
to say I told you so and I told you so
yesterday what would happen when we
start talking about rebuilding no trade
um we just don't have the intellectual
and spiritual and moral and religious
and cultural tools to be able to do it
in Rolling Stone magazine proved this
yesterday in one of the most egregious
and outrageous articles I've read in a
long time but it's actually a worthwhile
article because it does accurately
embody the problem that the West is
facing right now we'll get to that in
just one second but first let's think
about some peace of mind when it comes
to being prepared with food in case of
an emergency there are many different
types of emergencies you could prepare
for it everything is trivial as a power
outage to wildfires earthquakes floods
job loss all these sorts of things wise
company takes an innovative approach in
providing dependable simple and
affordable freeze-dried food for
emergency preparedness and outdoor use
wise company meals are designed to
protect your most valuable asset your
family when government resources are
restrained it can be days if not weeks
before you can get to fresh food and
water you cannot rely on someone else
you have to rely on yourself don't be
foolish you've got so much of value of
your life your family your property
everything don't just assume that
everything is going to go hunky-dory for
the whole rest of your life make sure
that you are prepared in the case of an
emergency
not only as wise emergency food great
tasting its quality is unmatched
they don't just slap their name on
someone else's products all their
ingredients or chef prepared internally
by wise company so they're really really
high quality it's very easy all you need
is four cups of water it doesn't even
need to be hot you take the contents of
the pouch pour them into the water you
stir cover that's it in 15 minutes it is
ready to go for your family no matter
what the situation there's no excuse for
waiting until it's too late
wise emergency food is an investment in
peace of mind for your family this week
my listeners get any wise emergency or
outdoor food product and an extra 25
percent off the lowest marked price so
already the lowest price you get another
25% off wise food storage calm and enter
Knowles canner wles
at checkout or
all eight five five four or five three
to nine four five shipping is free Wise
has a 90 day no questions asked return
policy there is no risk in taking the
initiative to get yourself and your
family more prepared today why is food
storage calm promo code Knowles get any
wise emergency or outdoor food product
at an extra twenty five percent off end
free shipping
can't beat that can you you might have
seen this going around Twitter this was
making the rounds yesterday from Rolling
Stone Rolling Stone put out an article
that said how should France rebuild no
trade on much of the structure survived
the blaze but as rebuilding efforts move
forward the country will be left with a
big question what does the cathedral
mean to 21st century France this is the
question what are we rebuilding what
country is rebuilding what is France
when when notre dam was built eight
hundred years ago France was entirely
animated by Christianity by the church
eight centuries later things have
changed dramatically what would it be
Rolling Stone wants to make sure that
you don't miss the point that they're
making they put it in really gross terms
quote but for some people in France
Notre Dame has always served as a
deep-seated symbol of resentment a
monument to a deeply flawed institution
and an idealized Christian European
France that arguably never existed in
the first place
the building was so overburdened with
meaning that it's burning feels like an
act of liberation says Patricio Del Rio
and architecture historian at Harvard
University Wow first of all leave it to
the American universities leave it to
Harvard this is the kind of person who
is teaching your children the building
was so overburdened with meaning that
it's burning feels like an act of
liberation imagine for just a second if
the al-haram mosque in mecca burned down
or half of it burned down or the roof
collapsed imagine that and then imagine
Rolling Stone writing and saying you
know for many
people the burning down of that mosque
which was so overburdened with meaning
felt like an act of liberation I don't
think they would say that would they
what does it even mean to be
overburdened with meaning actually it
does have a meaning it has a meaning in
the long history of Western thought the
meaning here is the central theme of
Western modernity which is liberation or
emancipation or whatever you want to
call it call it liberation I mean this
is the major theme of the West this is
the dominant theme of liberalism capital
L liberalism classical liberalism
left-wing liberalism liberalism itself
we sometimes forget because liberals
hate freedom so much it seems in this
modern time that liberalism is about
freeing yourself it's a net liberation
many times you'll hear conservative
critics say liberalism contains the
seeds of its own destruction so this
kind of crazy decadent suicidal culture
that we're living in now is the
inevitable result of the ideas of
liberalism when people talk about that
this is what they're talking about this
is what happens at the radical extreme
of liberation because it begins
especially in the modern era with
liberation first from institutions then
from the ideas themselves so it always
begins with the institutions and you say
well I don't want to just be tied to
some silly deeply flawed institution so
I'm gonna divorce myself from the
institution then I'm going to be able to
live in this pure realm of ideas but it
doesn't really work out that way what
happens is you divorce yourself from the
institution then you divorce yourself
from the ideas you see this most
obviously in the church so beginning I
mean this is a process that now has gone
on in our civilization for a thousand
years certainly since the Protestant
revolution you see a divorce from the
church then a divorce from religion
itself so even today plenty of people
who grow up in going to their local
church with their families grow up every
week maybe they go to Bible study or
something
what you see on the trend lines is those
people who then leave the church they'll
say well I'm spiritual but I'm not
religious because of the church whatever
church you belong to the Baptist Church
the Methodist Church the Anglican Church
Catholic Church whatever Church you
belong to you can always say it's a
deeply flawed institution obviously the
Catholic Church is a deeply flawed
institution Hilaire Belloc one of the
most famous catholic writers ever said
that the proof of the divinity of the
Catholic Church is the fact that it
still exists because any nearly human
institution that was conducted with such
knavish imbecility would certainly not
have survived a fortnight obviously you
can point to all of these other
religious institutions as well you can
point to the problems in the Methodist
Church or the Baptist Church or the
Evangelical Church or whatever so you
say okay I want to leave this deeply
flawed institution and that way I'll
have a pure sense of religion I've
liberated myself so now I'm just in the
realm of ideas but spiritual but not
religious or religious but not organized
religious or eventually you just divorce
yourself from the ideas as well think
about what's happened to national
institutions first you liberate yourself
from national institutions civic
institutions then you divorce yourself
from the nation itself we've seen our
commitment to religious institutions
decline dramatically over the past 40
years
what happened trailed by about 10 or 20
years people's declining in religiosity
itself as people pull away from the Boy
Scouts and the Lions Club and other
civic institutions what have we seen
trailing it by couple decades is less of
an identity with the nation itself how
about familial institutions as we
liberate ourselves from the institutions
of the family what happens we isolate
ourselves from family ties themselves we
have a society that has never been more
lonely never been more isolated this
happens this is what
Edmund Burke the founder of modern
conservative thought this is what he saw
is a perverse liberation in one of his
most famous excerpts from reflections on
the revolution in France he wrote
the age of chivalry is gone that of
Sophos ters economists and calculators
has succeeded and the glory of Europe is
extinguished forever never never more
shall we behold the generous loyalty to
rank and sex that proud submission that
dignified obedience that subordination
of the heart which kept alive even in
servitude itself the spirit of an
exalted freedom the unbought grace of
life the cheap defense of nations the
nurse of manly sentiment and heroic
enterprise is gone this is a very hard
statement for a modern Western person to
hear for a classical liberal or a modern
liberal or a leftist liberal or whatever
to hear that that dignified obedience
that proud submission that subordination
of the heart which kept alive even in
servitude itself and exalted freedom
what Burke is addressing here is that
you can't just liberate yourself forever
you can't just keep liberating and
liberating and liberating ultimately you
liberate yourself from all meaning you
liberate yourself from everything that
matters you liberate yourself from
yourself there there is this shallow
Liberty this shallow freedom and then
there is an exalted freedom which
actually requires some subservience it
actually requires some obedience we're
now we're in Holy Week now and Christ
who comes to free people from sin free
us from our own damnation how does he
come does he come as a guy who's totally
liberated who's walking around like a
modern 20th century liberated hippie guy
no he comes as a servant he is serving
he is submitting to the will of his
father he's serving others so what is
the ultimate liberation Rolling Stone
tells us but first before we get to what
Rolling Stone is telling us let's talk
about zip recruiter zip recruiter is the
best way to find people for a job super
cruder sends your job to over 100
the web's leading job words they don't
just stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and invites them to
apply to your job as applications come
in the zip recruiter analyzes each one
and spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match I really
benefited from the daily wire not using
zip recruiter when I was hired why is
this because my my whole resume was that
I didn't write a book I had just not
written a book it was a completely blank
book and thankfully because they didn't
use zip recruiter they accepted me and
gave me a show now we only use it
recruiter that's how we get the best
producers and all these people who were
actually really qualified for the jobs
they do right now my listeners can try
zip recruiter for free at the exclusive
web address zip recruiter comm slash
knowles KO wles it's so effective four
out of five employers who post on the
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
that is zip recruiter comm slash knowles
KO wles
as the applications come in zipper
creatures gonna analyze each one they're
gonna spotlight the top candidates so
you never miss a great match one more
time what is it zip recruiter comm slash
knowles KO wles
hiring is very hard finding the right
people is very hard if you make a
mistake in hiring you are going to
regret it's going to cost you a lot of
money it's more important it's gonna
cost you a lot of time don't put
yourself in that situation don't waste
money use the best way to hire zip
recruiter is the smartest way to hire so
what is the ultimate liberation
rollingstone tells us the ultimate
liberation here is liberation from
meaning they write this here they say
that the church the Cathedral of Notre
Dame was overburdened with meaning what
does it mean to be overburdened with
meaning I love me when you get a gift do
you really care about the material gift
itself no you always say it's the
thought that counts what we care about
is the meaning is the significance if we
don't care about meaning then everything
is just insignificant matter
everything is just flesh everything is
just stuff
everything is senseless meaning is what
counts so the ultimate liberation here
is the liberation from meaning you can
think about sexual liberation I guess
that's the most recent most
revolutionary one sexual liberation is
when you separate sex from meaning and
this is a great example because
meaningful sex carries transcendent
qualities so meaningful sex is the two
souls coming together being United
becoming one flesh becoming one spirit
is all of this stuff and meaningless sex
is a bunch of filthy people doing
something shameful it's the same
physical act but in one of them you have
this transcendent wonderful joyful
loving feeling and in the other one
you take a walk of shame in the morning
and you say go why did I have that extra
drink what was I thinking
that's what meaning does liberation from
meaning ultimately is destruction it has
to be destruction it's burning it all to
the ground you can't you don't liberate
yourself from meaning by adding meaning
you can't do that and when we build
things we add meaning we develop when
you when you take that meaning away it
just turns to rubble it turns to ash you
actually see this not just in the ashes
of the Cathedral at Notre Dom you see
this in the transgender ideological
movement I obviously I've been thinking
about this a lot the last few days after
there was a near riot at the University
of Missouri Kansas City because I made
the statement that men are not women I
thought why is this issue why is this
transgender movement dominating the
national conversation why was I attacked
by some weirdo with a squirt gun full of
chemicals for saying that men are not
women by all accounts the number of
people who are confused about their
gender is about 0.2 to 0.4% of the
population there are some new recent
estimates that put this number much much
higher that'll put it at double
basically at 0.6 percent of the
population even if that is the case
we're talking about this rare
psychological disorder that does not
affect ninety nine point four percent of
the population ninety nine point four
percent of the population at least maybe
ninety-nine point eight percent of the
population does not have this rare
condition and yet it is dominating all
political discourse social discourse
bathrooms pronouns all this stuff why
what is it about is it just because left
wingers have completely gone insane and
focused on this one little trivial
myopic topic no it's because this is the
theme of liberation this is the theme
that defines Western modernity
liberating yourself from your own nature
liberating yourself from the the basic
fact of your nature which is sex it's
how we get our nature in the first place
birds do it bees do it even sentimental
trees do it it is from our sexual nature
that we were born that we will be gotten
in the first place and as all those
silly scientific studies show men then
think about sex every 1.2 seconds or
something I don't know whatever they say
it is it's not that we're just focusing
on some little frivolous thing it's that
the impulses of liberalism are naturally
pushing us toward this madness this is
not just about some small percentage of
people who have this condition
it's about ultimate liberation from our
nature
you know the Communists and the
Socialists did this all the time they
say we're going to remake human nature
human nature is greedy and selfish and
broken and fallen and sinful it doesn't
need to be though well no that's okay
we'll just fix it this was what the
radicalism of the French Revolution did
and that's that's what this new gender
ideology is trying to do as well there
was an article in Scientific American
that came out I think just today it was
either came out yesterday or this
morning that is now advocating for
genderless pronouns they want to use the
singular they so it so it would be like
they is really hungry
michael is really hungry they is really
hungry maybe it's they are really hungry
maybe they conjugate the verb as though
it's plural too even though it's
referring to a singular it's very
confusing the first question of course
is why does Scientific American have an
opinion about pronouns at all why on
earth does scientific American think
that they can tell me how to destroy the
English language it's not the literary
America and it's not the grammatical
American it's the Scientific American
why are they weighing in on this aspect
of culture it's because first of all the
mainstream media broadly all have this
leftward push and because this is what's
coming out of the nature of the West the
nature of modernity when we think of the
modern era what do we think of we first
think of science we think of Western
science exploding in the I don't know
16th or 17th centuries obviously there
were many scientific advancements before
that but modern people in the West don't
want to admit it but that's what we
think of science and along with science
we have this theme of liberation that's
the first question
why does Scientific American have an
opinion on pronouns at all the second
question has even greater irony which is
why is Scientific American accepting a
completely unscientific premise the
premise here of the pronouns is that men
are not necessarily men and women are
not necessarily women and there aren't
necessarily only two biological sexes I
don't know maybe there are 20 or 30 or
56 genders like Facebook says the
premise here is completely unscientific
but the premises are the key the premise
is actually or the key because
ultimately what are we trying to
liberate ourselves from in when we're
thinking about it about logic when we're
thinking about arguments we're trying to
separate ourselves from premises this is
the kind of now cliche political line
they'll say if you don't stand for
something you'll fall for anything that
sums it up that actually does sum it up
you have to begin
any strain of thought with premises
nothing from nothing leaves nothing to
quote the great philosopher what's that
oh what's that guy's name Billy Billy
Preston one of the great political
thinkers of 1970s rock music nothing
from nothing leaves nothing you have to
begin with premises and because we're so
obsessed in the West with progress we've
forgotten that all trains of thought
require premises all logic all
argumentation is based on certain
fundamental axioms that you can't prove
it's based on certain fundamental
premises fundamental principles that you
just can't prove you can't begin with
nothing and get something you can't we
like to think that we can do that we
like to think that we can get all of
this creation all of this sense and
logic and meaning and matter and all
this stuff without a creator we have
creation all of which is contingent but
we think we can get there without an
unmoved mover a creator we think that we
can spin some if we spin something out
of nothing that will be the pure idea
that this this is the suicidal idea of
the West our arguments and beliefs begin
with first principles
if you don't assume the first principles
you will eat your own society you will
absolutely destroy it you get nothing
and we are uncomfortable with our
premises we are now uncomfortable with
the fact that we have premises so what
the Scientific American thinks here is
they're thinking well listen we want to
take away all bias all prejudice all
assumptions all questions of faith and
so we will apply this even to biological
sex we will apply this even to questions
of nature and so instead of he or she or
him or her we'll get rid of that that
might be prejudicial that might be
biased we'll just have they that seems
less biased that seems less prejudicial
that seems to make fewer assumptions
except it's not true they get one
fundamentally wrong which we will talk
about in a second but first look at look
at my beautiful soft face look how good
I feel
look at how nice I shave this is because
of Dollar Shave Club they have
everything that I need to look feel and
smell my best what I love even more than
that is that I never have to go to the
store in the olden days before a Dollar
Shave Club I often didn't go to the
store anyway so I'd use the same rusted
old razor I'd be giving myself tetanus
every time I got out of the shower this
is not a good thing because I was too
lazy to walk down the aisle I don't want
to have to go somewhere drive but no
nobody thinks about that Dollar Shave
Club has you covered from head to toe
for your hair your skin your face you
name it they have it they also have a
program where they will just
automatically keep you stocked up on the
products you use and I love their
products I love all this stuff I started
with them just for the razors because
they do have the best razor I've ever
used but they have everything they have
Dollar Shave Club toothpaste
is fabulous I take it with me on the
road it's great because they get gets
automatically sent to you so you don't
end up like me where you're squeezing
the last little dregs out of the thing
for three months no you'll get it new
act like an adult you'll feel great
right now they got a bunch of starter
sets you can try for just five dollars
like their oral care kit after that the
restock box ships regular sized products
at regular price so what are you waiting
for get your starter set for just 5
bucks right now dollarshaveclub.com
slash co f f/a co v fe fe that is
dollarshaveclub.com slash co f fa co v f
e f e now ladies don't really need to
worry about shaving their face generally
speaking this is a fact of nature what
the Scientific American wants to do is
reject scientific premises so they think
they think that they the vey singular
pronoun is totally inclusive it's
totally unbiased it's totally
unprejudiced actually it's just a
different premise it's just a different
prejudice it's just a different leap of
faith to say that that sex is
meaningless that there isn't really no
biological sex that sex can change and
it's muted
that's just a different premise and one
that's really difficult to stomach I
mean this is why people have never
arrived at this idea that's why we've
only started thinking this for the last
five seconds or so what Scientific
American is trying to escape to liberate
themselves from this overburden of
meaning all they're doing is assuming
something new and they'll get sick of
this one they'll get rid of the singular
day they'll move on to something else
the issue here is that we are demanding
to be everything to everybody and you
can't be we will explain what this means
for the West in just a second but first
I've got a second byte of Facebook and
YouTube go over to Daily wire comm 10
bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the Andrew
Klavan show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get to ask questions in the mailbag
you get the Matt Walsh oh by the way
mail bags coming up tomorrow so make
sure to get your questions in you get to
ask questions backstage you get another
Kingdom you get all this stuff and you
get something much much better than this
plain white coffee cup I'm on the road
so I don't have my leftist here's tumblr
last night I was with drew Clavin at
Texas A&M which is I think the most
conservative university on the face of
the earth so I didn't need my leftist
ears tumblr luckily I survived that's
how I'm able to broadcast to you today I
won't always be so lucky you certainly
won't always be so lucky get the leftist
ears tumblr it's the only way to survive
the deluge that is coming go to daily
wire comm we will be right back
this is what we're doing we're demanding
to be everything to everybody that's all
we want all we don't want to offend
anybody this is why everyone is so timid
now in modern American culture as well
and I just I feel like I don't want to
offend you I don't want to state an
opinion or a fact I won't even say I
think I won't even say I believe I'll
just say I feel like I now when I hang
out with my left-wing friends I noticed
this they never disagree with each other
I mean they do obviously people have
disagreements they have different points
of view but they'll never openly
disagree with one another they'll say
yeah yeah no that's true that's true
some guy says yeah you know I think that
the moon is made of green cheese you say
yeah yeah no I see that I see that
that's true yeah but also maybe it's
it's made of rock you know but your but
your opinion is true too because you you
can't be wrong because we cuz ever it's
cool we're all it's all good it's all
the same it's all right it's all true
this is why universities now have
offices of diversity and inclusion how
Orwellian does that sound if you've told
a guy if you took a time machine back to
the way way back days of like seven
years ago and you said that a university
would have an office of diversity and
inclusion they would say what kind of
Orwellian nonsense are you talking about
what on earth does that mean but it's
the inclusion you get you want to bring
people in you want to nothing can be
exclusively true everything has to be
true everything has to feel good
everyone has to be included you know
when I was in college the president of
the college was a left-wing guy for sure
but he had more a more old-school
liberalism or an earlier stage
liberalism before this crazy liberation
from meaning and he one time said
something very profound he said the
truth is arrogant the truth is arrogant
what does that mean the truth is
exclusive the truth is not inclusive the
truth would not do very well if he got
called into the Dean of diversity and
inclusion true statements exclude untrue
statements true conclusions from certain
premises exclude other conclusions you
can't be everything to everybody I had a
friend of mine it's great guy left-wing
kind of guy and we were talking about
religion and he said why can't all
religions be true you know I mean you
know man why can't you be Christian and
Buddhist and Jewish and Muslim and Hindu
why can't you just be like all of those
things you can't be all of those things
because they make conflicting claims two
plus two cannot at the same time equal 4
and equal 5 God cannot at the same time
have one nature and then have a nature
that contradicts that nature those two
things two opposing things cannot be
true at once you can't be everything to
everybody a painting is a painting
because it's not a photograph coffee is
coffee because it's not orange soda why
can't it be both it can't be both a
cathedral is a cathedral because it's
not a mosque it's not a mosque no tre
Dom is not a mosque it's not a synagogue
it's not a whatever Buddhists have I
don't know what Buddhists have it's not
a brunch cafe it isn't those things they
clearly they're very upset about this
that certain things cannot be true at
once the left hates this fact the left
hates the fact that a thing cannot be a
different thing Tahlia lovin of The
Washington Post
went after Ben yesterday went after
little ol Ben Shapiro because been
called Notre Dom a monument to Western
civilization so she writes in The
Washington Post quote
shortly thereafter fast-talking
far-right pundit ben shapiro called no
trade ah what a monument to Western
civilization and judeo-christian
heritage given the already raging rumors
about potential Muslim involvement these
tweets evoked the specter of a war
between Islam and the West that is
already part of numerous far-right
narratives what so been said that no
true DOM is a monument to Western
civilization and judeo-christian
heritage this is obviously true you see
it in the facades you see it in the old
Old Testament imagery in Notre Dom you
see it in the New Testament imagery you
see this is obviously a monument to
Western civilization it's an embodiment
of Western civilization and and she said
that by even using that phrase by saying
that no true DOM is Western is
judeo-christian it is therefore
anti-muslim because it's not Muslim no
true Dom's not Muslim it's Christian
Judeo Christian in so much as Christ as
a Jew and therefore it's not Buddhist
it's not Hindu it's not Muslim it's it's
not those things even the phrase Western
civilization is now considered too
exclusive for the left and this is the
irony because Western civilization is
the only inclusive civilization in
history Western civilization is the only
civilization that says come on come in
come in you can be part of this
obviously in America anybody can be an
American Americans look completely
different if you point to someone and
you say is that person an American you
couldn't tell by the color of his skin
or the way he looks or where he's from
or even how he talks this is even true
in Europe it's less true because these
countries are based on people's the
france is based on the franks england is
based on the angles but even in europe
you have people especially after
colonialism especially after imperialism
europe bree and all of these people to
Western civilization spreading Western
civilization so you've got the most
inclusive civilization in history and
yet for liberals for the left it's too
exclusive for the liberators it's too
exclusive and this is why we can't
rebuild nutri dom we can't do it because
were too busy liberating ourselves from
our civilization we're too busy
liberating ourselves even from the thing
that defines us Emmanuel macron the the
head of France promised to rebuild no
trade on more beautifully than before
now IC is trying to make the country
feel better they've just lost this
pillar of their country and their
civilization
you're not going to rebuild no trade on
more beautifully than before it's not
going to happen because the trouble here
is that beauty is particular homogeneity
is sterile it's clinical it's ugly it's
unpleasant beauty is particular beauty
is in the spire of no tree Dom that we
saw collapse in flames
beauty is in every little nook and
cranny of every little statue on that
facade you'll notice in modern
architecture everything is flat
homogeneous sterile clay it's all the
same there's nothing particularly
think of modern office buildings think
of modern churches modern churches and
no trade on look they're not they don't
even look like they're in the same
category
modern sure they're all sleek they're
all flat they're all you can put on them
any idea you want there's nothing
particular about them but the beautiful
ancient cathedrals and medieval
cathedrals those are particular and it's
something in our whole culture we want
to say there's no such thing as men and
women there's no such thing as
differences of thought or differences of
idea there's no such thing as any of
that it's all the same it's all the same
but of course not beauty is particular
think about why you are attracted to
your girlfriend or your spouse or your
husband or your boyfriend or whatever is
it because they're completely plain
looking and they look exactly like
everybody else and everything's exactly
the same no it's her eyes or her nose or
others or other things maybe or her hair
which is why Joe Biden is attracted to
certain women many women it's because of
these particular things if I said
describe your wife to me you wouldn't
say she's completely plain she looks
exactly like everybody else no you
wouldn't you would go on about these
particular things the same is true of
ideas the culture that created no trade
on that was able to build Notre Dame
Cathedral is a very particular one it's
it's particularly a culture shaped by a
particular man who is God incarnate who
lived in a particular place at a
particular time who was crucified at a
particular time who conquered death and
rose again on a particular day who
formed a particular church that spread
throughout particular places that's
where that beauty comes from that's
where every statue on the facade of no
tree Dom every relic every work of art
every beautiful aspect of architecture
comes from that particularity not from
this plain-jane sterility it's one of
the great lies of our era that detail in
particular things are bad and plain
generic clinical cynical things are good
this is a great lie in it but it does
affect the way that we think it affects
our very thought ice there was a tweet
that came out yesterday from Library
Journal which I haven't subscribed in
years to library journal I don't know
about you I there is apparently a
journal called library journal and
library journal now believes that
libraries are tools of white supremacy
if it weren't so hilarious it would be
tragic and it is tragic
library journal sent out this tweet they
said quote library collections continue
to promote and proliferate whiteness in
their very existence and the fact that
they are physically taking up space in
our libraries which which I got to tell
you if I were an ethnic minority I would
be very offended by that tweet because
what you're saying is that books are
white reading is a white activity
writing is a white activity following
arguments to their
logical conclusion that's a white
activity on that so that's whiteness
itself a very offensive statement to
make and what library journal was doing
is linking to this weirdo blogger lady
sophia leung lyon and so i read the blog
entry and so much as it was coherent or
understandable i read it and this is
what she wrote quote if you look at any
united states library's collection
especially those in higher education
institutions most of the collections
books journals archival papers other
media etcetera are written by white
dudes
writing about white ideas white things
or ideas people and things they stole
from people of color and then claimed as
white property whatever that means
so she says most of the collections are
written by white dudes this is true most
of the people in the history of Western
civilization are white dudes that's true
and it's a testament to Western
civilization actually that they're able
to include other people who don't look
like them other civilizations don't do
that but then she goes and says white
ideas what's a white idea inclusion and
diversity I guess that's a white idea
that's kind of ironic isn't it it does
appear to be a white idea a civilization
of white people came up with those ideas
and then brought everybody else in
that's pretty good idea I guess it's a
white idea that becomes everybody's idea
but it's a it's also a distrust of ideas
themselves saying even ideas or tribal
we cannot actually communicate what is
the purpose of a book the purpose of a
book is to put down ideas narratives
thoughts artwork and you put them from
out out of your own head you put them
down on paper then you hand it to
somebody else and then that person can
have those ideas in their head it is
communication it's bridging gaps between
people's and what Sarah looks Oh Sarah
long Sophie along and library journal
are saying is no II that is not possible
communication is not possible that that
premise is not possible and then then of
course she contradicts herself because
she says they're white ideas
stolen from people of color so I guess
there are people of color ideas whatever
those idea I don't know what those ideas
are either and then they're claimed as
white property again whatever that is
okay and library journalists posting
this this is the iron right you've got
library journal saying that libraries
are terrible this is a telling example
of what the West is doing constantly
this is a telling example they're just
constantly saying we hate ourselves we
hate our peoples we hate our
institutions we hate our culture we hate
our religion we hate our nation's we
it's the suicide of the West this is
what is meant by that phrase this is the
suicide of the West and this also helps
to explain the madness that you see with
these left wingers the other day when I
was in Kansas City and I'm looking there
at these crazy protesters who were
shrieking and screaming and they face
we're oppressed and they've got this
far-off wacky look in their eye I saw
madness I saw insanity at Texas A&M last
night the topic of the discussion with
me and drew was can we survive the crazy
left this is a madness but it's a
madness born out of some psychological
condition but of a philosophical
condition of erasing our own premises
because when you go back far enough and
your cell camera or erase our political
institutions I'm going to erase our
cultural institutions and we're erase
our religious institutions I'm gonna
erase our assumptions then you're left
with nothing you're left with a blank
mind this is what is meant by the phrase
when the left always says you've got to
open your mind conservatives are
closed-minded this is always ironic
because conservatives are much more
willing to entertain different ideas
than left wingers are however they say
we've got to be open-minded open-minded
and what the left does they do open
their minds they open their minds so
much that their brains fall out and so
there's nothing in there just it's like
you could play pong all day inside the
head because there's nothing in there
and it's this is by design this is why
the left always says we've got to listen
to the children listen the
system from the mouths of babes we've
got to listen to because it's a it's an
elevation of ignorance because they
think that knowledge wisdom maturity
ideas premises conclusions all of that
what that really does is it just amounts
to bias and prejudice and bigotry and
exclusion because the truth is arrogant
so what you've got to do is get all of
that out of there
so little children who are completely
ignorant they don't know anything
they're the ones we should listen to
that's why we need to lower the voting
age because they know those little
children because they have nothing going
on in their heads they are the most
likely to give us a good government to
give us a good culture because they're
not filled with bias they're not filled
with prejudice this is ultimately the
what the left always does is attack the
tradition this is what liberalism
ultimately is liberating us from how do
we find a meaning how do we find our
history how do we find our culture it's
in traditions this is why what
conservatism ultimately boils down to is
the tradition all the various kinds of
conservative thought what unifies them
all is basically a defense of the
tradition maybe one aspect of the
tradition over another but that's what
it is and it's why intersectionality it
makes sense to left-wingers is because
even if you've got various victim groups
who all hate each other who all disagree
with each other who are skeptical of one
another
what they all have in common is they
want to attack the tradition they want
to destroy it they want to burn it down
to rubble they want to liberate
themselves from it they want to
emancipate themselves from it and the
only way to liberate and demands your
emancipate yourself from meaning is to
burn it down and once it's burned down
once it's in ashes then the left-wing
liberal liberating innovator comes in
and says we will rebuild it more
beautifully than before this is what
they told us during the communist
revolutions we're gonna burn down human
nature we're gonna send them all off to
the gulags but we're gonna rebuild it
more beautifully than before every
totalitarian system
and it's what the naive Emmanuel macron
is saying we are going to take the ashes
of this Cathedral and rebuild it more
beautifully than before rebuild it on
what nothing from nothing leaves nothing
a sad note to end on but it does explain
the madness it does go a long way to
explain our current cultural madness is
there some way to restore sanity perhaps
there is but we can't burn things down
you can takes 200 years to build a
cathedral
it stands for 800 years you can burn it
down in 66 minutes are we willing to not
just let the whole world burn it we
willing to rebuild it how are we gonna
rebuild it we're gonna have to start
rebuilding ourselves rebuilding our
civilization that's it all right we'll
get too much more tomorrow there's
there's always more to get to but we'll
have to do it tomorrow I'm flying out
I'm probably gonna miss my flight in the
meantime I'm Michael knows this is the
Michael Nolan show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins and directed by Mike
joiner
executive producer Jeremy Borah senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Joshua
alvera
and our production assistant is Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright day Lee
Weyer 2019 hey everyone its Andrew
Clavin host of the end ruk laven show
the Muller report is scheduled to be
released tomorrow the press and the
Democrats but I repeat myself are
already spending it every which way but
the one way that tells the truth that's
on the Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew
clay